how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and as
we patiently await that spider-man
trailer 2 which is actually the official
first full trailer for spider-man no way
home we actually have some pretty cool
news to talk about in the meantime
regarding spider-man no way home welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
about the mcu and recently about
spider-man a lot spider-man no way home
is one of the most anticipated movies of
all time at this point and luckily for
us we are just getting tons and tons of
new information about it pretty much
every other day and today we have to
talk about the spider-man no way home
post credit scene what it could be we
actually got a little bit of a hint and
at least one of the post-credits scenes
will actually tie into some other things
that have been happening within the mcu
now and we also have to talk about some
new spider-man no way home photos which
of course i'll break down everything in
this video also we'll be announcing the
winner for the spider-man action figure
within a couple of days so be sure to
subscribe to my channel and subscribe to
cosmic culture and leave some comments
on some videos only a couple days left
in the giveaway so this is rather
interesting there was a reddit user that
went by the name my time to shine hello
that had recently leaked a lot of
accurate information about spiderman no
way home a lot of this information was
confirmed to be true when the first
trailer came out so this person's track
record for leaks in regards to
spider-man no way home is outstanding
and recently they made a twitter account
now at first we questioned whether this
was actually the real person or not but
this person went on reddit and confirmed
that it is indeed the same person and
this person posted a few days ago
halloween scoop for y'all remember it
well i'll go back to it when no way home
is released tom holland's peter parker
will get the black symbiote suit in the
mcu after no way home now obviously the
black symbiote suit is venom and we're
talking about the venom post credit
scene because the movie has been out for
long enough to where you should have
seen it or at least heard about it by
now the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene pretty much does back up
this report however it adds a little bit
more to the post credit scene we know
that venom is now in the mcu that's
pretty much what we know the rest of it
is very confusing whether morbius and
everybody else is over in the mcu now or
whether it's just venom but we know that
venom and eddie brock are now in the mcu
and the post-credits scene came after
tom hardy said that he's going to do
everything that he can to get venom and
spider-man to go up against each other
that combined with venom licking tom
holland spider-man through a tv screen
probably means that whatever is coming
after no way home is going to involve
venom and it won't just be spider-man vs
venom somehow spider-man is going to
wear the black venom symbiote or somehow
get another black symbiote which i think
would actually be kind of cool because
essentially you would have spider-man
venom vs regular venom but here's the
thing i asked around to other insiders
about what this could possibly mean and
each one of them told me that they
pretty much believe it is going to be
the post-credits scene for spider-man no
way home at least one of the
post-credits scenes because i do believe
that they will do some type of
post-credit for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and technically
according to this leak the post-credits
scene would take place after no way home
because originally i thought well maybe
peter will go into a different universe
and perhaps in this universe he'll pick
up the black symbiote for just a little
bit and then leave it in that universe
and move on but this report specifically
says after no way home which could
heavily imply that it is indeed going to
be the post credit and we have to
imagine that sony is pretty in sync on
what they're trying to do within the mcu
and marvel studios of course is right
there with them talking about the story
and how they're moving forward so
aligning two post-credit scenes probably
does make the most sense we have the
venom post credits scene that shows
specifically tom holland spider-man then
in theory spider-man no way home will
have a post-credits scene that talks
about or shows venom in some way shape
or form or like i said maybe it is just
another black symbiote for the longest
time there's been a very interesting
theory that spider-man knowing home
could perhaps introduce the fantastic
four because of that huge avengers tower
being renovated we still don't really
know any information about this building
yet a lot of people thought that it was
going to go on to be ozcorp but since we
got the morbius trailer yesterday and
they showed us a new oscorp building i'm
starting to doubt that oscorp is
actually going to be in the mcu after
all the green goblin that is going to be
in no way home isn't going to be from
the mcu he's going to be from the sam
raimi universe perhaps in our universe
norman osborne decided to do something
else with his life but again the
interesting theory is that this building
could actually go on to be the baxter
building the headquarters of the
fantastic four now i'm not really sure
on what marvel studios plans are to
introduce the fantastic four but hear me
out for a second what if the fantastic
four go into space because that's what
they do and somehow they bring back a
symbiote from there perhaps peter parker
gets involved with the fantastic four in
some way shape or form we don't really
know what's going to happen in
spider-man no way home whether people
are going to know that peter parker is
spider-man by the end of the film but
perhaps the fantastic four do know about
spider-man and perhaps they know that
peter parker is somewhat of a genius and
somehow they team up maybe through an
internship or maybe through a job this
could lead to peter parker getting very
close and coming in contact with the
symbiote again i kind of like this one
it introduces the fantastic four
obviously and we see the fantastic four
interact with spider-man but two it
would be a different symbiote than the
actual venom symbiote because of the
actual venom symbiote goes to peter
parker what exactly is eddie brock going
to do i know it's happened in the comics
but i am strictly thinking of on-screen
mcu you'd have a lonely eddie brock in
new york city where he normally is not
at then you'd have a very very
overpowered spider-man now don't get me
wrong there are tons of stories that
they could do with this and they could
even have venom attached to spider-man
and spider-man reject him him go back to
eddie and that's where we get the whole
venom hate spider-man storyline and that
would be fantastic that would be great
but it would also be cool to kind of see
spider-man get his own symbiote and go
up against venom and eddie regardless of
what happens it's gonna be epic and i'm
all here for it and it looks like there
could be a good possibility that we see
spider-man tom holland spider-man come
in contact with a symbiote in the
post-credits scenes for spider-man no
way home now as i mentioned we have a
photo to go over a lot of you saw this i
posted it on my instagram and my twitter
it's a picture of spider-man in that
same scene on the bridge where we saw
him fighting doc ock it looks like he's
falling off of something holding on for
his life or perhaps a car got thrown at
him or both but eagle-eyed fans have
spotted something in this shot it looks
like under his right shoulder we can see
a reflection of what he could possibly
be looking at and it looks like it could
be the green goblin's glider now this
would make total sense because in the
teaser trailer for spider-man no way
home we already saw the pumpkin bomb and
we kind of think that this is all going
to be in the same scene peter parker
slash spider-man taking on doc ock and
the green goblin at the same time
probably in this bridge scene we know
the villains are going to be held in
some type of a prison and then they
escape and then we could probably assume
that peter is going to chase after them
and they attack him i actually assume
that this bridge scene is one of their
first encounters and fights after
they're let out of the prison let out
escape whatever it may be regardless of
whatever it is peter's going to try and
fight them and bring them back to the
magical prison hopefully there will be a
lot of fights and i hope that this is
just one of them it sure does look like
that as the glider and again that would
make perfect sense because we've seen
the pumpkin bomb but let me know what
you think have you examined this photo
do you think it's the green goblin's
glider let me know and let me know if
you think we'll see peter parker
spider-man wear a black symbiote in the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter and tick-tock and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you